víctimas de las redes de tráfico de
personas los ataúdes de 4 afganos que
murieron ahogados en un intento por
cruzar el Canal de la Mancha desde
Francia hasta Reino Unido fueron
llevados a una mezquita en la ciudad de
Lille en el norte de Francia cerca de
100 personas muchas de ellas afganas que
viven en la región se reunieron para el
recital de la oración fúnebre islámica
estoy muy contento con el gobierno
francés porque el gobierno británico no
los ayudo
dilog y los cuerpos eran transportados a
París y luego embarcados en un vuelo
para su repatriación a organizan a pesar
de esta tragedia cientos de migrantes
siguen intentando cruzar el Canal de la
Mancha para llegar hasta Reino Unido
este mismo jueves un grupo de migrantes
encontrados en alta mar fueron llevados
a la costa inglesa de que en un barco de
rescate esta situación se repite a
diario y ha sido una fuente de tensión
entre Francia y Reino Unido
especialmente después de que 27
inmigrantes se ahogara en el mes pasado
una crisis humanitaria que ha sacudido
la diplomacia mientras que Londres dice
que París no hace lo suficiente para
vigilar sus cosas los franceses acusan a
sus vecinos detener leyes migratorias
laxas que atraen cada vez más a los
migrantes